every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed you know I bet that
you'd be fine without everybody is
Joshua fields Melbourne recording a
quick podcast intro from a hotel room in
California which is a bit of a
coincidence because we have a live
version of a podcast we recently
recorded in California beautiful Los
Angeles California Ryan and I were on
tour a couple months ago and so what
you're about to hear is is a live
version of one of our podcasts we took
our documentary which is called
minimalism a documentary about the
important things to more than a dozen
cities and we after each event we
answered questions with with the live
crowd there so questions about the film
but also questions about minimalism and
decluttering and relationships and
mental clutter and finances and sort of
everything in between and speaking of
being on tour Ryan and I have a couple
additional tour stops coming up in the
near future we're gonna be in Fargo
North Dakota we're speaking at a
conference there but then we have a
separate tour stop scheduled for July
19th we're gonna screen our documentary
and then we're also going to do another
live version of this podcast so that's
Fargo North Dakota and then after that
in August on August 11th we're gonna do
a special special charity event in
Orlando Florida this is gonna help the
victims of that recent horrible shooting
in the Orlando night club the terrorist
attack there and so we're trying to help
out the victims and you can help out too
we'd love to see you there there's still
tickets to both of those events over at
the minimalists com slash tour and
speaking of the film and still playing
in theaters right now in the United
States but also some new dates in Canada
and Australia you can find all those at
minimalism film calm and while you're
there if you if you're interested in
pre-ordering the film or if you're
anywhere else in the world and you can't
see it in a theatre then you can find
the details for that as well if you
preorder the film which comes out on an
August 2nd but if you get it before the
on Vimeo you get six hours of bonus
interviews and content with their great
stuff there we just couldn't fit into
the film but we're looking forward to
being able to share that with you as
well
find all of that over at minimalism
film.com and here is a live of version
of our podcast where Ryan and I recorded
this in front of a sold-out crowd in Los
Angeles California a couple months ago
hope you enjoy it
alright let's hope hopefully Shawn's
ready Shawn make your bird call if
you're ready and I want to welcome a
Jeff and Marla Sarris to the stage well
hello everybody welcome to a live
version of the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and we are live in Los Angeles
so normally how this works is we take
callers they'll call up and they leave
us voicemails on a voicemail box they'd
be really weird if we took calls right
now and so instead of instead of that
you all can pretend to be the callers
but live in person so we'd love for you
to come up and ask a question if you
have one now you could ask us a question
about anything could be minimalism or
decluttering or mental clutter health
relationships careers
Ryan's hair care products whatever you
like and we will answer your questions
and if I don't have an answer for your
question I will just answer a different
question we have a bag of answers up
here so feel free to ask whatever you
want you will get an answer if you want
to form a line here we'll we'll get
started with the questions the first
person has to break the seal though this
is a shy city
alright hey you say your name and
whatever your question is hi my name is
Bill Black and I'm well on my road to
minimalism and I hit it you got the
outfit man just saying no the part like
no you got the outfit black t-shirt
jeans oh thank you very much did you buy
it so on April Fool's this year we we
put on our website a black t-shirt and
for seven hundred twenty nine dollars
and if you look really close the folks
from spire they designed they made this
beautiful like box and it was velvet
lined and but he looked really close to
the t-shirt it had a Hanes
tag on it it was fruit of the Loom fruit
of the Loom and it was seven hundred
twenty nine dollars now we did the math
on this and if everyone who clicked the
Buy Now button now I realized that not
everyone who clicked the button would
have actually purchased the 700 L
t-shirt but if everyone would have
purchased it it would have been about
six million dollars and it turns out
we're in the wrong business we need to
be in the fashion business I'm sorry -
do you really man go ahead as you can
see I hit a milestone last weekend I had
two boxes left they've been sitting
there for like a year and I was actually
at the LA minimalist meeting we just had
and I said I'm down to two boxes I just
got to do something with it I did it
that day after it's gone it's the
empties scanned giving away whatever the
boxes are empty
I kept the boxes they're in the closet I
just look at them and I keep going and
looking here's that here's the question
okay I used to gather a great pleasure
from you know the new iPhone then you
get gadget and I've changed my ways as
well sure a lot of us have I keep I used
to get this momentary pleasure from
buying this new thing we all know what
that's about
now I have this sustained pleasure from
just looking at those two empty boxes
the question is give me the psychology
behind it it's the exact opposite of
what I used to get it's I'm happy about
nothing can you
you what a great book title copyright
pending so the cycle
the psychology of hoarding they've done
some studies with with chimpanzees and
bonobos and we find that when you give a
chimpanzee a banana he or she will eat
the banana right but if you give the
chimpanzee more than one banana and
enough to share so that he or she has
enough for himself and and feel secure
with that but enough to share they will
share with the the people of the people
the chimpanzees hey chimpanzees are
people too
yeah so they will they'll share it but
if you give them an entire horde of
bananas more bananas than what they
could possibly share it will they won't
not only will they not share but they'll
they will fight other chimpanzees to try
to keep them away from the bananas so
maybe the the opposite of that is
letting go and I mean I think the
difference between us and chimpanzees is
you know we have this frontal lobe that
allows us to - that allows us to to
think about security and realize that
the real security is different from what
we've been this meme that we've been
sold of security this American dream of
security we've been told that if we
accumulate enough things then we'll be
secure if we have the right paycheck the
right job title the right identity the
right clothes the right car the right
house then that equals security you hear
this other term all the time job
security right but the truth is we don't
feel secure when we get those things the
opposite is often the truth we then
become scared to lose that thing just
like the chimpanzee they acquire this
horde of bananas you know a thousand
bananas and all of a sudden now they're
just terrified they're going to lose it
and I think once we realize that we've
lost it and it's okay in fact it's even
better without then we realized that the
feeling that that that check-out line
high that we got it doesn't last far
past the checkout line and it certainly
doesn't last and once you get that
credit card statement and you're like oh
[ __ ] like now I have to pay for this or
you get that first car payment and bill
in the mail and you realize okay the the
actual price of this thing isn't just
the price tag it's anxiety it's
overwhelming stress it's happening to
take care of it and store it and clean
it and occupies space in my mind and
keeps me from being free in many cases
and so that's my short answer yeah it
made that question made me think about
like like my diet and how for the
longest time I conditioned myself to eat
really bad food I mean Josh and I we've
been friends since we were fat little
fifth graders we were literally like the
two fattest kids in our class and you
know we we had a lot of cheeseburgers
and cheese fries and cheese nachos and a
lot of other cheese related products we
would we would munch on after school I
guess we were constipated a lot it was
that was like our literally like our
after-school snack before we go home and
eat dinner um but what I know is that
after changing my diet over the last
many years I I have conditioned myself
through habits to enjoy healthy foods to
the point where and I'm really gonna
offend someone I'm so sorry but like I
went to in-n-out burger today for the
first time ever and it was right I mean
you know it was but I think it's because
I'm so used to not eating that stuff
that my I just wasn't conditioned to
like really embrace the the fast-food
nosov that still very tasty don't get me
wrong but but I think the same thing
holds true with with your situation
where you have now incorporated really
good habits into
life and it's kind of you know through
that conditioning that you've been able
to to kind of now enjoy nothing hi my
name is Paul and I was wondering if you
had any specific advice for us living
here in Los Angeles because it is very
expensive to live here we have areas of
town that a lot of people want to live
in where average rents are going you
know twenty five hundred three thousand
dollars and life here is pretty
expensive auto insurance isn't cheap
and I think a lot of us like living in
Los Angeles we have friends and family
here and you know as much as you know
I'd love to come and move with you in
Montana you know I do actually have a
lot of people around here that I that I
really dig tiny houses you know that's
that's kind of a wonderful idea
forty fifty thousand dollars you own it
you don't owe the bank anything but here
in Los Angeles there are laws that are
actually designed to keep us from living
in these small spaces you know so you
know like it would be great but I mean
there are like very specific barriers
from that the kind of have us working to
make a lot of money just to live here
and I just wanted to know if you had any
specific advice for for us that want to
continue living in big cities and you
know and have a better quality of life I
guess yeah so it's an interesting thing
because it's a bit of a paradox that the
question ultimately comes down to to
what do you value most right in fact
people in New York or Chicago or LA will
often ask us how can I be a minimalist
in the city because it's so steeped in
consumption and consumerism and while
that is certainly true and it's but and
that drives prices of the cost of living
up it's also true that in many instances
it's easier to be a minimalist in a
large city because you have access to to
far more things and I think we are we
are pretty
rapidly shifting from a a culture of
ownership to a culture of access no it
doesn't mean that I'm against owning
certain things that that's not the case
at all there are many things that I own
that I get immense value from but I
don't have to own a swimming pool to
have access to a swimming pool I don't
have to have a basketball court in my
backyard to to to have access to
basketball but now we're seeing that
with technology bleed over into all
these other areas of life that we never
expected 10 15 years ago you know I used
to own 2,000 CDs I used to own 2,000
books I owned 4 or 500 DVDs I mean I had
a hundred VHS tapes when I was when I
was going through my whole you know
minimizing process no one laughs at that
because they're kinda logging the the
VHS tapes that are in their basement
right now but but the truth is that I
don't need to own any of those artifacts
anymore
I now need access to them so I don't
have to go by the deep every DVD for you
know 15 bucks or whatever and own that
thing I can have virtually unlimited
access for a much lower price so we're
finding that we have access to more
things than ever now that they're a
curation problem then comes into play
and we could talk about that some other
time because we we certainly need to -
as Patrick grown talked about in the
film we need to have a certain
discernment when it comes to weeding out
the junk and curating what we watch but
but now we have we have access to to so
many things and you get that most in a
big city like this the question then
becomes is what I value is is that worth
the cost of me being here and for me yes
relationships are are very important and
can you be healthy in this city or or
does that need to take it does it take
being somewhere else to to be healthy is
this a city that I can pursue what I'm
passionate about and be creative this is
a place where I can grow is there a
community that I can contribute to as
well and when you start asking these
questions
you'll figure out whether or not it's
the right place to be so whenever I'm
asking those questions it becomes
twofold can I afford this
like monetarily afford it but not just
money can I afford you know the the the
clutter and and the time and attention
that a city like this may take from me
and and ultimately what it comes down to
is the opportunity cost of that versus
does this add value to my life and is
this the the best scenario for me and it
sounds to me like for you like waltz
Angeles is a place you want to be and it
becomes difficult to be able to to
afford it and and I'm sure that is a
problem for for a lot of people and I
don't think there is an easy answer to
say well we need to make more money or
spend less I mean those are all I mean
yeah that's something I did with my life
was you know I I made really great money
in the corporate world making $200,000 a
year in Dayton Ohio is probably like
making more than two hundred thousand
dollars a year in Los Angeles right and
when I walked away from that I my first
plan was to be a barista and work it
there's a coffee shop two blocks from my
apartment and just write fiction
full-time and work at working that
coffee shop write fiction and then this
whole minimalism thing happened as a
really beautiful accident and and I can
tell you that that year I walked away I
went from making a couple hundred grand
and making twenty three thousand dollars
a year and I had never been happier but
I had never been more responsible with
my resources as well
and I finished paying off debt that year
I and I realized that the discontent
that I had around money when I was
growing up poor was the same discontent
I had around money when I was making
really good money is I wasn't spending
it as wisely as I could
Jeff and I live in Chicago so we can
relate we you own a home and I can tell
you that we considered selling our house
but we get great value out of our home
it's our home you know we love to travel
but we live right by O'Hare so it's
really easy
for us to hop on a plane from where we
live and and that I think that
everything that Josh said is spot-on and
you just need to keep questioning the
things that you invite into your life
yeah I love LA man like I was just
telling Josh in the greenroom I'm like
dude every time I come to this city like
I just feel so good like it's the just
like the people and the awesome weather
and like the awesome restaurants but I
know that if I moved out to LA like I
would be house poor essentially and
that's a decision that I that I make
like to not move out to a city like this
if I had a bunch of friends and family
out here I might be willing to go house
four to stay close to those folks but
you know ultimately if you're asking for
ways to you know kind of live in a city
and that has expensive rent or it's
expensive real estate I mean there's
always options like Airbnb you can rent
out an extra room make some extra money
but yeah there there is a decision that
has to be made because when you live in
such an expensive place it does require
you to get a job where you make a lot of
money in that if you're forced into that
situation it can make you make a
decision to take on a job that might not
necessarily align with your values and
beliefs and and I think like that y know
that's definitely where I was where I
didn't care about selling cell phones to
five-year-olds
you know I cared about like I need to
make six figures like that's what's
gonna make me happy and ultimately now
you know let's say the internet blew up
and all of our books spontaneously
combusted in like I had to go back and
find a regular job and I had to move to
LA I'm just like trying to relate here I
would I would totally you know I would
probably you know start off really small
rental rooms for somewhere and like try
and save up some money and then you know
if I wanted to buy a place have a you
know 30 40 percent down payment but yeah
it would certainly approached a lot
differently than just moving out here
and you know jumping into a job that I
might be miserable at well you're making
movies now so maybe we'll see you in
Hollywood
Thanks thank you hi guys hello buddy my
name is Justin Archer hey brother first
and foremost I just wanted to
acknowledge you guys and the whole
minimalist team for all the amazing
content that you put out from the blog
to the books to the essays to the
podcast this film it's all amazing that
said no that said if all of it were to
disappear don't hate me I don't want to
jinx anything but if all of it were to
disappear what would be and and you were
on your deathbed I didn't really plan
this going this dark really anyone bed
what would be your top three life
lessons or life truths you would like to
leave behind as your legacy Josh you
can't change the people around you but
you can change the people around you
we'll just go one two three four I like
that yeah I you know the the whole love
people and use things because the
opposite never works that to me rings so
much truer than money doesn't buy
happiness because we're all raised with
that platitude of money doesn't buy
happiness but you know the that that's
saying implies the same thing but I
think that's what those would probably
be my last words I would really want
people to connect with I see your five
fingers I applaud you for that we have a
site called paleo porn so we do a lot in
kind of that space we're very into that
but it's all thought it's food porn not
we're not porn porn but sort of
everything that we've that's brought us
to where we are today with what we do
with sort of long minimalism with with
our lifestyle with food and everything
else it really comes down to decisions
and there's no right answer there's no
right way he says there's no template in
the film because there's not everyone is
going to have a different
and it's essentially a compass as long
as you have your compass set in the
correct direction everything is going to
work out you sort of look at things
generally from a map perspective a lot
of people want to do of tactics and
things like that
but it's all just a bunch of little
decisions it gets us to where we are
today and I think that's one of the kind
of key things that I'd really want to
kind of convey to people go bears give
out your website real quick is he he
does some really great like I don't you
call physical therapy videos and stuff
I've been watching lately and I've been
doing some of the routines while I've
been on the road I don't know if he even
knows that but you want to go your
website yeah it's the posture guy.com
and also can I get one of those free and
transferable hugs from you guys oh yeah
you can come on up here hug best job
when I was little I really wanted to be
a lawyer and then when I grew up but the
idea of debt sort of scares me because I
already have $40,000 in college debt so
I did want to switch careers how should
I go about that transition as a
minimalist thinking you know about all
the debt that it would require to go
through two years of your law school and
work in things like that yeah so in
terms of debt I I never encouraged
anyone to take on any new debt at all
ever there's no such thing as good debt
I'm gonna say that again there is no
such thing
as a good debt there is some debt that
is more acceptable than other debt
obviously right like having a mortgage
seven-year mortgage with 50% down and
and a you know a secured ability to pay
on that is appreciated better than
getting a payday loan at a corner store
but the truth is that all debt is going
to it's going to be an anchor for us and
at the very least it may get to you to
where you want to be but there is often
another template to get you where you
want to be so my question would be to
you if if you really are able to
cultivate that into being a career that
you're passionate about and in fact I
don't like the term career but if you
find that you know being an attorney is
your mission I have a CPA back in
Missoula Montana so our accountant is
really passionate about accounting I
have no idea how someone is really
passionate about accounting but Ryan is
really passionate about snowboarding and
I have no idea how someone is passionate
about snowboarding and and so when I
look at other people's passions I know
that they've been able to cultivate that
into a passion but I also know that
there are there are attorneys there are
accountants there are snowboarders
there's whomever who got to where they
are there's a certain percentage in some
cases a small percentage you've got to
where they are without acquiring any
additional debt any additional student
loans so I mean whether it's becoming a
doctor
and and going with like a National
Service Corps for a couple years and
they they sort of pay back your loans
for you there is someone else who has a
model or a template that you can follow
and so the first thing I would encourage
you to do is question is this something
I can cultivate into a passion am I
going to be passionate about this or is
it just a means to an end and it's just
a means to an end I would probably tell
you to try to find something else you
can cultivate to passion but here's the
good news you weren't born with a
pre-existing passion you weren't meant
to be an astronaut or an attorney or
yoga
instructor or whatever and we in fact we
hear that all the time right you should
just follow your passion right you see
it like in self-help books and on blogs
and and anse accessories posters at
universities often follow your passion
at shitty advice the better advice is to
cultivate a passion because you weren't
born to do any one thing but there are
dozens likely hundreds of things that
align with your values they align with
your beliefs your interests your desires
and you can cultivate one of those
things pick one of those things and
spend time cultivating that into a
passion now don't confuse excitement for
passion and I think quite often we get
really excited about an idea and then of
course when for me it was it was writing
and and I would get really excited about
an idea for a new short story or a novel
but then after working on for a day or
two days or a week or two weeks I'd hit
a roadblock a roadblock and it would get
hard and I'm like oh
obviously I'm not passionate about this
because it's difficult I'm just gonna go
get on email or check Facebook or watch
TV and because I'm not passionate about
this thing and I learned throughout my
20s there was no real payoff because I
did wasn't willing to put in the work I
wasn't willing to Drudge through the
drudgery and and it wasn't the writing
didn't align with my values it certainly
did a line with my values but I had to
put in the work I had to put in the
effort because the real payoff the real
passion comes after the tedium after the
resistance after those mundane tasks and
called really cultivating that into a
passion after doing the work and so find
some of the lines with your values and
then find someone who has a template
someone who has gotten through law
school or whatever other path you want
to take without taking on any more debt
because I guarantee you you can find
someone who has done that and pick their
brain you'll find a way to do it without
going into debt there you go there you
go talk to her afterwards right here
yeah I kind of had one more question
okay go ahead what
presidential candidate nominee is most
minimalist in your opinion
don't make it too political just okay
Josh in 2020 yeah I'm sure the year this
this year the the most minimalist
president we ever had was a man named
Calvin Coolidge in the 1920s he was
really the minimalist president and and
we had the best economy we've heard of
the Roaring Twenties and the reason he
was such a good president is he did what
a president supposed to do is he
presided over the country and wasn't
this dictator or authoritarian we don't
have anyone like that now and I don't
want to say there isn't hope for someone
like that in the future but but
currently our options are are slim and
and we do have options though at a local
level and I think it's far more
important to be involved locally than it
is and this yeah national dog and pony
show for sure
and by the way oh one of us is a
socialist and one of us is a libertarian
so we're not going to talk specifics
thank you I was struck by not not just
what a profound effect this could have
on my life but also the profound effect
it could have on my family's life
especially my grandmother who's you know
in her eighties I was curious in your
experience what were kind of the the
best key steps to taking that first big
step to declutter in your life and kind
of starting on this journey for for
newcomers Jeff what's what's the the
easiest way to force her grandma all to
become a Mentalist
definitely a packing party no but to
really we just need to lead by example I
know you're asking about kind of the
first steps but you referenced your
grandmother and we've been minimalist
for seven or eight years we've been
paleo for six we've we've been doing a
lot of things making these decisions for
ourselves and we've seen amazing benefit
like it's the quality of life that we've
experienced has grown immensely neither
of our families are either minimalist or
paleo and you could say they are the
polar opposite of both of those and
that's actually okay though because it
really we don't need to really change
anybody we're living in but we think a
great life what how we want to lead it
and people end up just sort of coming
along it it takes time everyone it takes
more time for others because we all
different experiences we're coming from
a different place but yeah really just
leaving by example is I mean from our
perspective really the best way yeah so
he talked about the packing party for
those who don't know about the packing
party um that's that was my first step
where we literally packed up all my
belongings in my 2,000 square foot condo
three bedrooms two bathrooms and I acted
like I was moving essentially so I would
unpack things day by day as I needed it
that's probably too extreme for a lot of
people as a first step especially those
with with families um but what I was
gonna say is you could maybe try doing
the men's game with with your grandma
that's worked for tens of thousands of
our readers where they will find someone
who wants to declutter get rid of some
stuff so that's kind of the first step
if she has to at least want to declutter
a little bit but it but it's a fun game
because you get rid of one thing on the
first day of the month two things on the
second day of the month three things on
the third day of the month so forth and
so on and you guys can bet a dinner or a
movie or you know the winner
I'm sorry the loser has to cook dinner
for the winner or something like that
but yeah certainly if you both make it
through the whole month you both went
because you get rid of about 500 items
each but that's a nice way you know a
palatable way to kind of get into it
without having a packing party or you
know renting a dumpster and just
throwing away everything that's that's
also a pretty extreme she would you know
it's still possible for her to be
completely miserable if she just like
threw everything away but yeah that the
men's game or even a packing party in
like a linen closet you know something
something small like that that's pretty
good start yeah I'm gonna give you a
copy so I don't feel like I'm selling
you a book or anything I'll give you a
copy of on our books called essential
and there's 12 chapters on sort of the
12 different areas of it starts with
decluttering and minimalism and then it
moves to other areas of life as well I'd
love to give you a copy afterward if we
can grab one for you I think that'll be
definitely beneficial for her and a lot
more tips and practical rules that you
can help her out with for sure I'm
getting the wrap-up from Shaun so I have
three people left online let's do
rapid-fire tweetable kind of questions
and we'll try to give tweetable type of
answers hello name is Nick I just wanted
to go over something interesting I went
through the material aspect already for
the past few years but what I've noticed
now is I'm trying to get to a level of
pursuing the things that are most
valuable and I'm noticing that due to
cost of living debt that you cannot get
rid of like student loans things like
that it's a choice of having to work
extremely hard to the point where
actually did two full-time jobs last
week almost rolled a car off the highway
and overnight just said forget it it's
not worth it quit but then you're back
to the same boat so the question is how
do you become the minimalist you want to
be pursue the things you want to do when
you're wrapped up of trying to live in a
life that requires you to work really
really hard and put those things on hold
in order to get to that level and I
think that's something especially here
in LA a lot of people will experience
yeah I think first and foremost you have
to have a plan on how to get rid of the
debt if you don't have a plan I'm gonna
recommend Dave Ramsey's total
makeover it's a freaking awesome it's
just it's really good man but but you
know I think when people hear simple or
they hear minimalism they think easy and
simple is not necessarily easy I mean
that for the first year and a half of my
journey it was working 60 70 80 hours a
week going to school and writing for the
website that was not sustainable but I
knew that the end was near and I did see
the end in sight
so if you don't have a plan like get a
plan and then the the the next biggest
thing is you got to stick to that plan
and yet I mean you might have to work a
couple jobs for a short period of time
but but as long as you can see that end
inside it's a lot easier to kind of get
through that but yeah if we get get that
Total Money Makeover man if that's if
you don't have a plan right now if you
can what the plan the the Ryan I use to
get out of debt but also to start saving
for the future you can just go to the
minimalists comm slash freedom and
there's an essay there called financial
freedom five difficult stuffs to get out
of that because they're not easy stuffs
they are it is difficult but it's well
worth it because you remove that anchor
from your life
you experience it totally new kind of
freedom and I wish you a lot of luck
brother
Julia hi my name is Jessica and I just
want to say first of all congratulations
on the documentary it was very inspiring
I also want to give a big shout-out to
your publicist I work in publicity I
know how tough it can be you guys have
these rooms packed
I saw the sold-out listings on your
website congratulations it's great to
see people out doing something positive
it's changing lives so I just wanted to
applaud you for all of that I read your
book everything that remains and one of
the questions that I had that I was kind
of curious about I didn't see a lot of
in the book was when you did make that
transition from getting off the
corporate ladder and deciding okay I
want to live a more meaningful life how
did that feel when you first kind of got
out of that I mean I think a lot of us
probably feel that you know that
adrenaline and you're in it you're in it
every day and I'm just kind of curious
what that transition was like and any
advice that you have you know
for that transitional time so I was a
teacher for six years and after Jeff was
fired from his job
I quit mine so we were kind of building
our business and it was scary I would
never advise anyone to quit their job
make sure you have a plan in place it's
all about having a plan and knowing
where you're going and we've had that
plan and we figured things out but it's
initially super scary and there was a
ton of groundwork I mean I worked in
Asuncion in a cubicle for seven years
and I had been building the business
that became what we have now which is
called spire and it was one of those
things that was by no means an overnight
kind of transition it would took a lot
of work but then when I end up losing my
job it was actually a huge relief
for me not for her she was a wreck but
but it was a relief because it actually
sort of for me was that kick in the
pants to really take things to the next
level now to start from from zero just I
mean because a lot of people sort of
sort of glamorize like putting your job
it's gonna be amazing and everything so
much better but it's it's not it's not
that easy it takes a lot of hard work
and laying in that ground work ahead of
time is really going to be important to
make that transition but when you're
ready for it it is going to be the
greatest day of your life have you ever
seen those on the side of the road there
there are these when you go through like
Wyoming and and parts of Montana the and
they're even parts of California for
runaway trucks
yeah there's little ramps that given the
runaway truck an opportunity to stop
before you know falling off a cliff
that's kind of what it felt like for me
that the I was a runaway truck and I had
spent all of my 20s climbing this
corporate ladder and going faster and
faster busier and busier and busier I
was working 80 hours work
I worked 362 days a year and I felt like
crap I felt like I didn't have control
anymore it was a runaway truck and but
when you slam on the brakes and you go
from 100 miles an hour to functionally 0
miles an hour it's still really
startling and and so I wasn't prepared
for how startling that would be where
you just sort of sit there and the cab
of the truck and shake for a moment and
realized that I'm not scared of what's
going to happen in front of me it's just
my I'm scared of what did happen already
and I certainly don't want that to
happen again
Thanks hi my name is Rebecca my
questions for Joshua I'm a writer too
and I'm kind of experiencing what you
had referred to during that other
question where kind of have an idea and
then like it fizzles out and then go do
it the next idea so I'm just wondering
like how exactly you got to a point
where you could focus more and like also
where did that come like on your
minimalism journey I spent most of my
20s as an aspiring writer which means I
didn't write very much but I aspired
every damn day
and you know I realized that our our
priorities aren't what we say they are I
used to say my health was a priority but
I weighed 80 pounds more than I weigh
now they said my relationships were
priority but they were in shambles
because I was spending time with
tertiary relationships coworkers and
networking buddies and executives and I
used to say that writing was a priority
for me but I wasn't spending time really
doing it right and I used to say other
things were priorities but the truth was
our priorities are how we spend our day
we're not all born in the same
circumstance we don't have the same
resources but we all have the same 24
hours in a day and we get to decide how
we're going to spend those 24 hours and
so I started reprioritizing some of
those hours and for me it was first it
was one hour so I used to get up at 5:45
every morning and I said okay well I
don't have another hour in the day now
I'm not advocating you stop sleeping but
I started get up at 4:44 every morning
my alarm was set for 444 I wrote for one
hour every morning and the the four most
powerful words that were ever told to me
was by a writer named Donald Wright
Pollak he's a novelist and and he said
sit in the chair that's it just you have
to do the work you have to sit in the
chair no distractions nothing else it's
not about page count or word countering
these other things you just have to sit
in the chair you have to be willing to
do the work and I think that's powerful
metaphor even if you're not writing or
whatever else whatever creative endeavor
project thing you want to do you have to
put in the hours and eventually I
started making time three hours a day
and that really crappy writing started
turn into slightly less crappy writing
and eventually turned into better
writing and so forth and so on but it
came from putting in the work writing is
a weird thing because we expect to get
better via osmosis yeah I've never heard
of an aspiring carpenter someone isn't a
carpenter because they put in the hours
and that they're willing to do the work
and I think the same is true for most
professions and we just need to be
willing to to sit down in that chair and
and do the work you got to make it a
priority and if you're spending your day
on email or Facebook or Instagram or
whatever else it just means you're
saying yes to that which means you're
saying no to writing or whatever else
you want to do before we close it I want
to thank some folks did did you all hear
the music in this film how amazing was
that so so a reporter asked me recently
we were I was talking to the newspaper
and and she said it sometimes they ask
them at the strangest questions and I
think it's like trying to there's
strange questions upfront try and loosen
you up said if you're trapped on a
desert island
with one album what would it be and
there's a ban from uthal originally
called parlor hulk and their second
album is an album called parlor hawk and
it would just came to mind instantly
like that that's obviously the album
that i would if i was on a desert island
i can listen to one album for the rest
of my life it would be that album and
the the lead singer lee singer for that
band is a guy named andrew Cap'n ER and
about three years ago I started begging
him to make the the music for this film
and after talking to him for about six
months we actually became pretty good
friends and I've just loved his music
and so he partnered up with a guy named
Nate Piper who is a really talented
grammy-nominated producer and it made
the music in this film for next to
nothing and because it was a project
they they really believed that and so
drew was here tonight I'd love for him
to at least come up here and grab a hug
really quick really appreciate you
brother
and I'm told that he and Nate so they
formed a band just for the for the film
it's if you google their their names we
vve right and you google it you're not
gonna find anything because they formed
a band that's the type of stuff that he
does like he'll just do random creative
stuff like that and we I'm just so
grateful that the soundtrack to this is
amazing they just sent me a final
version of a week it less than a week
ago and I think Ryan and I were talking
about this before we've played it out by
now I've listened to the thing a hundred
times already and so a lot of the things
the songs you've heard on there they've
added vocals and some other stuff and
I'm pretty sure they're gonna have it
off within the next week or so so you
all will have access to that
thanks so much true appreciate your time
we've been on the road about a month and
touring is crazy expensive and we don't
do like regular advertisements or
anything like that but Ryan I started a
blog six years ago but we didn't know it
was called a blog at the time and we
couldn't even spell HTML and in fact I
remember like after we had started the
the web we called a website and what
we're over essays because we didn't know
what a blog post was and and so I called
him about a month in I was trying to
code this entire web site and HTML I
like reading books at the library and
I'm I just call them one day and I'm
like man I cannot do this anymore I'm
done I and we finally figured out about
this thing called WordPress and how to
host your own site and and our hosting
company is a company called Bluehost and
I reached out to them beginning of this
tour and said hey would you be willing
to give us some money to help us travel
to get this message out to more people
and they said yeah and they've been
really supportive of this movement over
the last you know quite a few years now
and I just want to say thanks
Blue Hose they're the reason we're able
to travel out here tonight so thank you
so much and what about this theater how
awesome is this can we thank them give
them a round of applause as well so our
artists our distributor is a company
called gather films and they're here
tonight so they we have a interesting
relationship with them we were
approached by them initially we're just
gonna put this out online but now it's
gonna be in about 400 theaters starting
May 24th that's coming Tuesday actually
and it's because we partnered up with
them and they're hosting helping us host
screenings all over the United States
and and all over Canada as well if you
enjoyed the film you want to share it
with other people there's other
screenings going on but you can also
host your own screening as well just go
to minimalism film column click on see
the film and you can help bring it to
your community if if you found the value
in the message but I wanna say thanks
together since they're here tonight
let's give them a round of applause
so at the end of all of this if you
don't want you know to get these
disgusting hugs from two sweaty
minimalists then that's okay you can
exit through through the right side here
but if you want to line up we're gonna
do hugs and and books if you do get a
book from us
be sure to minimize it afterward
obviously and if you didn't bring your
wallet with you you can't afford a book
tonight that's okay well it's on us feel
free to take a book please we that we
want to buy one for you it's another way
that we can definitely get the message
out so you know pass it on to someone
else who can obviously get value from it
so we'll start a line over here at the
end if you want to if you want to line
up and grab a hug or pictures or
whatever we're doing we're doing all
that right and most important I want to
thank you for being here we every
sold-out event that we're doing we have
six hours of bonus content that we're
gonna send it because they're fun we did
a thousand hours worth of interviews for
this or of footage for this thing a lot
of that was interviews so we're gonna
have about six hours of a lot of the
interviews that were in here expanded
but also some interviews that we love
but they just didn't make the film
including some stuff with drew that we
filmed and it just didn't make the the
final cut of the film so you'll get when
it comes out online this it'll come on
August 2nd I believe it is it'll be out
all over online and everyone who
pre-orders the film gets it but anyone
who attends a a sold-out screening of
the film gets those six hours well so
we'll email all that to you but before
you leave I just I just really want to
say thank you we really appreciate you
being willing to spend this time with us
you could be anywhere in the world and
you chose to be here with us and we're
really really grateful and I hope you
grab a hug afterward and of course if
you leave here with one message I hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for your time yeah
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
you're green you know I bet that you'll
be fine without every little feeling
that you got a hand every little thing
that you got you gotta reach for and you
got a grand oh I bet that you'll be fine
without you
so cheer your team
you